the number of satellites circling the
earth has skyrocketed in recent years
in 1959 there were just two satellites
in orbit
but today there are well over three
thousand and that's just the beginning
private companies are scrambling to
conquer space at a rapid
pace spacex's starlink project alone has
permission to put
12 000 satellites into orbit in 10 years
time there could be at least 16 000
satellites in orbit
five times as many as today the rush to
space
is driven by falling prices 25 years ago
payload
payload cost per kilo was 22 000 euros
today it costs only a thousand euros and
those prices are expected
to keep falling to less than 100 euros
per kilo no wonder then that more and
more companies are looking to the stars
data from space will be key to unlocking
new technical innovations in the future
navigation communication earth
observation
more satellites are delivering ever more
data a huge market according to this
startup in berlin
we are convinced that every major
industry will be affected during the
next 10 years
by satellite data so to give a very
precise example what we can do with
satellite data is for example monitor
infrastructure grids
all across the globe but also monitor
mines monitor
agricultural fields monitor forests and
so on so really for every global
question there's an
answer from space live eo evaluates
satellite images with the help of
artificial intelligence german rail
operator deutsche ban
is one of their customers from orbit
it's possible to see where trees are
growing too close to the tracks
it helps safety personnel do their job
more efficiently
data analysis can also be useful for
monitoring power grids and pipelines
we have customers from australia to
europe
to the u.s south america and so on just
at the beginning of this year we've
analyzed the entire u.s transmission
network nearly 1 million kilometers of
overhead lines
uh so really there's no limitation to
what satellite data can monitor in terms
of scale
and nearly nothing in terms of scope
satellites are getting smaller
and cheaper the company astrophine has
established
itself as a supplier in the field these
reaction wheels can be used to steer
satellites and align them with the sun
they're packed and released into orbit
from boxes like these
[Music]
the reason that small satellites are
starting a revolution
is because the barrier to entry is not
that high anymore
if you build very large satellites that
carry a lot of instruments
it costs a lot of money but if you make
the satellite smaller
miniaturize the components take
advantage of the increase in efficiency
then you can put something into orbit
faster with pocket-sized satellites that
cost maybe 300 thousand euros
and then you can launch your business
model
the industry is on its way from the
workshop to mass production
giants weighing tons are turning into
smart swarms
that provide seamless data the raw
material of the future
and for more i'm joined by walter pelzer
who is an executive board member of the
german aerospace center in bonn
welcome first off can there be too many
satellites in space
i can imagine the risk of collusions for
example wouldn't that be bad
yeah good morning first of all thank you
for having me and you're absolutely
right it's kind kind of crowded
around the around the globe and
so traffic becomes an issue and this is
a topic we have to handle
um with with agreements and we are
working
in intergovernmental agreements
with the united nations to come up with
a solution for this topic
now you spoke of multilateral
organizations like the united nations
but the sp and the space
sector was of course once dominated by
public agencies what do you make of the
rise of new space startups and private
companies getting in on the game
yes actually there's a reason why why we
have this significant change and we we
monitor it
and we we see it for for quite some time
now
uh a few reasons and in the in the
report uh
most of the reasons were just mentioned
by miniaturization
uh it was mentioned that satellites
become cheaper
and so it becomes cheaper to enter the
business is
much cheaper and the risk lowers so you
don't have to spend
millions for a satellite anymore it's
just a question of a few hundred
thousand euros
or dollars and launch costs
getting lower as well due to the fact
that satellites are lighter the
cost for launch is getting getting
easier but this is only one one part why
we have this change to so-called new
space
actually the the initial from my point
of view the initial
uh ignition of the new space was that
nasa changed his purchasing process that
they changed the way how agencies
um are on the market up to now and this
is something we in europe have to
to do as well at least from my point of
view
is is that agencies in the past actually
said exactly what they want to have and
they
gave an order and nasa changed this
process a little bit that they asked now
for a service
so they create a market they say okay we
are willing to buy
some kind of service for example some
lunch service
for so many millions or billions
and now it's up to the private market to
come up with offers
so everybody can actually step in and to
say yeah okay
we can we can offer you a solution for
the
the question you have for the service
you are asking for and this is a
completely
change in the process so it sounds like
you are for
europe opening up more to uh private uh
to private companies
how is europe doing as a competitor in
the space
race relative say to the us or china
well to be honest i think we are um
maybe not in the first row but we are we
are catching up
um as i just mentioned um the european
space
agencies on the one hand side but also
the the european um
industry has to adapt to this no process
into this new process so and uh this is
on the one hand side on the second
uh part which is actually making this
transformation a little bit more
difficult is that the size of the market
in the u.s is so much bigger
the same in china in us we see more than
14 launches per year
of course the payloads with more than 40
payloads or
actually a few times as much as 40
launches
um the same in in china and
in in europe we have not not even five
institutional
launches per year so the market size is
much smaller
so the willingness to invest in a much
smaller market
is uh on a lower level and this is
something we have to develop
walter pelzer is an executive board
member of the german aerospace center in
bonn thank you very much
you're welcome thank you for having me
you